if you can't sell you don't make money
period and the statement entrepreneurs
have one thing in common they keep going
they'll change the rules they'll
reinvent the rules if I had to do it
again I go work for McDonald's
Juanes or get a mentor what's up Live
Nation that's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best Robert
Kiyosaki and his five secrets to having
success as an entrepreneur mentor me
Robert
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn how to sell
I am very shy very very shy and I came
back from Vietnam and I could kill
people but I couldn't talk to people and
one day I said to my my decided to
follow my rich dad's footsteps I just
said to him I want to be an entrepreneur
he says you got one problem I said
what's that so if you're shy I said
what's wrong with being shy he says you
gotta sell you got to handle rejection
number one skill
can you handle rejection answers no I
couldn't handle it so I stole it while
we're having cell so now this is the
1973 I was 25 years old and my Rich Dad
said how's your love life so it sucks
getting laid they said no so this
because you can't sell guys got it so
when I talk about what skill do you need
when the [ __ ] hits the fan
you better start selling so I went to
work for Xerox in 1974 so I learned how
to sell it took me four years then I was
number one okay and today I'm a
best-selling author
you know most PhD is telling me I can't
write yes I said I can't write but I
can't sell if you can't sell you don't
make money period and the statement you
know just because you have a product
doesn't mean jack
but the important thing is you start you
know I don't care what product you start
with what you start and I started off
with dylon wallets success wiped me out
you know we couldn't sell could itself
also that it took off then I couldn't
finance it couldn't finance to put in
finance but the sales kept going through
the roof now trouble is I kept borrowing
and it couldn't sustain the sales next
lesson but that's how we learn ok rule
number two always be a student I'll wake
up tomorrow morning and you're on the
street and you have nothing you don't
have a single contact and your network
all you have is the knowledge and
experience that you've had throughout
your career how do you build up from
there well I've been there many times so
it's no big deal you just figure out
what's needed I'm why don't you go do it
you know I'll always kind of dump on
what he called a fast-food industry if I
had to do it again I go work for
McDonald's and the reason I go work for
McDonald's you know brother has 7 bucks
an hour or 15 I don't really care I
don't really like McDonald's food but
they have the best business systems in
the world
you know how else can a company take
virtually non college-educated people
and build a fast-food industry across
the world and they have the best system
so right inside little McDonald's you
can learn everything you need to learn
about business except for the management
side of it so I just go work at Donald
so I can learn even more so I look at
life as learning I'm constantly learning
you know I reading cause of my studying
constantly I spend most of my time with
entrepreneurs I don't spend my time with
people who complain about the economy
you know so nothing we really change I
just go back to being an entrepreneur
rule number three learned through trial
and error how does an individual that's
opens themselves up to learning you know
actually make sure they don't get sort
of roped into the wrong advice and the
wrong teaching unfortunately as part of
the process you know I've had bad
teachers as well as good teachers that's
part of life that's real life it's like
how do I know she's the right woman for
me should I marry her I don't know or is
he the right man for me I don't know if
you don't know you don't know and
sometimes you don't know it till after
you get married it's the same as money
there's there's no real answer to that
the trouble is those schoolteachers tell
you there's an answer there isn't an
answer
there's trial and error there's learning
gonna make mistakes I've made a lot of
mistakes but I've never been very good
for me because I've learned from them
but schools tell you if you make
mistakes you're stupid yes when they
should support they don't make enough
mistakes or if they make a mistake they
don't learn from them rule number four
have an entrepreneurial mindset
entrepreneurs have one thing in common
they keep going they'll change the rules
they'll reinvent the rules you know they
don't just take one answer so a real
entrepreneur really it makes no
difference which country you're in
that's my belief so I not I love that
you know I mean it's a mindset you know
it's fu you mess with me I'll find a way
around it
you know I have a friend is multi Multi
multi family rich guy from France and
that you know Frances was communist ik
as it gets
seventy five percent top line four
million dollar earners yeah that's why
he loves here so he he started buying
vineyards in Napa and Sonoma so he went
back to the French government he says
it's his wine he says I want to ship my
wine in bulk to California and the
government says you can't do that
some what French governments and you
can't [ __ ] and here's the guy is I think
his five generations
you know French wine guy this guy's this
guy is an entrepreneur entrepreneur he
says okay I can't shipping in barrels a
guy goes yeah he says okay open bottles
baby bottles all of his stuff it cost
him more money but he still figured out
how to do it if you do know I mean and
now he has his wine with his California
wine and all this and so he went back to
the French government's here try this
see if it's not better and so now
they're all confused because he didn't
break any rules so I'll say it again
entrepreneur is a mindset first a skill
set and rules and depending upon whether
you're an employee or small business the
rules are different the mindsets are
different the skill sets are different
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip is work more
give more I don't know what the heck
with people think about money but that's
what I get a lot of is kind of this well
you know money is not spiritual I'm just
saying it's your attitudes you know the
person's attitude towards money I make a
lot of money but I give a lot you know
what I mean in fact it goes to biblical
principle the more you give the more you
receive so when I meet somebody who's
not doesn't have any money it just means
that they're not giving something yeah
you know so a lot of times there's
people who would like more but they're
not giving anything yeah so they're like
my poor debt you hate belong to the
labor unions and he wanted to work less
and get paid more well that's anti
religious to me yeah if you want to get
paid more work more give more that's how
I see it
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Robert on how to be a team player
that I think you're gonna enjoy the
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions on the
move from just watching under the video
to actually taking action in your life
or your business and if you're feeling
bold leave your answers in the comments
below here we go question number one how
can you practice your sales skills today
number two what do you need to be a
student in and learn more and number
three what idea can you test this week
through trial and error
yes I'm one of those kids who doesn't
like school you know school is good for
people who like school but here was my
poor dad ahead of Education PhD on the
governor's Board of Hawaii and all this
stuff and his kid me and I'm flunking
out of school because I can't read I
can't write I said I couldn't read I
couldn't write I was bored out of my
mind you know how's this Hey
so what I did instead was that's when I
met my rich dad was my best friend's
father and he used these things called a
game see games are the best teaching
tools see when I'm playing this game
this is how the rich taught their kids
battle strategy is called chess my rich
dad taught me to be a rich man playing
Monopoly we played Monopoly our hour
after hour you know the formula for
great wealth of Monopoly is for green
houses one red hotel so today in Arizona
I own 8,000 green hotel I mean
greenhouses and several red hotels I
just played Monopoly for real so that's
the power of a game because a game
engages me mentally physically because I
access the moving emotionally because
when somebody knocks me out yeah I
better wake up you know I made a mistake
and spiritually because it's spirit that
wins no fuses all Golden State play that
play they you know everybody and I love
LeBron James
I love Cleveland you know but one guy
cannot take on a team and I think LeBron
or 60% of all the points in assists and
all that but a better team beetle so
when you look at business business is
the same thing but this is a team sport
I have to have good accountants good
attorneys good marketing guys good tech
guys great staff have to have great
leaders you know the trouble with most
entrepreneurs are self-employed so they
quit their job and you know in America
they the SBA the Small Business
Administration
twenty-eight million small business
owners
twenty-eight million twenty four million
are classified as non employers murder
one man team you know the bail like this
guy said okay I'm going to take you on
are you crazy
but that's what most entrepreneurs are
trying to do because that's what they're
taught to do in school to be the rugged
individual you know in school I was very
successful as long as I could cooperate
at test time but in school cooperation
at test time is called cheating in the
real world the guys have the biggest
team win so all I focus on is putting
the best team together meanwhile a lot
of time to a students in school that the
doctors a lawyer sitting there all by
themselves they're sitting ducks but
they're entrepreneurs
then that means this in mindset tactics
strategy I went to military school I'm a
former Marine so I think like a military
operation which I love chess so most
most entrepreneurs you know they have
this job okay I'm gonna be an
entrepreneur in this crisis massacre
because they went to school they learn
to get a job and they take tests on
their own they have to be the smartest
that's like the LeBron James
I don't want being a smartest guy in my
team but I want to have the best team
and that's why I win most of my games
that's great I think like this and the
doctor stick like this and fight yeah I
got you man yeah for some reason I get
the sense I'm gonna win the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you don't do these eight things you
will fail if you want to know what they
are check out the video next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you
want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories